when it comes to living a full life it's
never too late to start and these
inspiring seniors are here to prove that
age is just a number
I am Ernestine shepherd 80 years of age
i benchpress 110 pounds I started
training at age 71 I was named the
oldest female competitive bodybuilder at
the Guinness Book of World Records my
sister and I started exercising together
I had never done any type of exercising
before before she died she said promise
me you will follow my dream and try to
get in the Guinness Book of World
Records so that's what I did
[Music]
I have been in six or seven competitions
I win but some I come out second and
third and I'm pleased with that
[Music]
I'm up every morning at 2:30 after I
have my devotions I walk in a run
approximately 10 miles I'm at the gym at
7:30 and I have a group of ladies that I
trained
I trained all ages one of the youngest I
think she's about 20 years of age and
the rest go from 40 all the way up to 80
when people come to my class for the
very first time they are really really
surprised they said I didn't think this
exercise would be this tough but if you
can do it we are going to do it too
I really don't feel as though I'm 80
years of age but I am I want to keep
training until my day is done next team
sports can be demanding especially on
ice but this player keeps coming back
for more
oh my goodness I played you I guess you
might say forever
probably about 1931 is when I first
started I'd be 85 years of thought to me
that I've been playing hockey
I'm mark circuit I'm the oldest ice
hockey player in the world I'm 95 years
old hope to be 96 on July 18th I'm still
playing hockey three times a week I get
up at 6:00 in the morning I do my situps
my push-ups and a few other things that
kind of loosen me up and then I'm ready
to go yeah
and when you live about a mile away but
I do drive down by myself and it's funny
but I'm usually the last one there I'm
the one that lives it closest the group
there consists mostly of some former
firefighters and also of course the
current one so there's a it's quite a
different mixture there I think about my
age and once a while I say to myself
well you know you're only 59 you're not
95 I just turned the numbers are on you
make myself feel better
my love for hockey is is hard to explain
you're speaking with the puck you're
shooting the puck you're trying to take
the puck away from the other guy there's
so many different things you're doing
this it just keeps you going there
everybody's got it wrong I'll keep
distance you you just keep finishing it
if the coach keeps putting this out
there or doing something right
[Music]
there is a greatest bunch of guys I've
ever played with he sent me up all the
time and sometimes it gets to a point
where I'm almost embarrassed that I'm
not scoring more because they're always
giving me the puck a group of the
players right after hockey go come over
to my home and we sit down in the
kitchen and discuss who did what on the
ice and so on and so forth at my age is
a wonderful way of being connected with
younger people and I think that's very
important for for an older person I'm so
fortunate that it gives me a chance to
be involved it's just really the best
thing that's ever happened to me
what better place to make friends of all
ages than school this sophomore might be
the oldest kid in the class but he's
forever young at heart
due to an EF no Garmin that was in my
heart afford our own David in MA
George ephemeral Varma pop until until
Magento mirin and are given in class -
Mira Mumia 69
[Music]
we're gonna top this new trucker that's
what is Srilanka not about digital Aman
wanna be saying when you go
some are Ziegler is Anna thinking your
mother 1/4 moment Abba see an America
sorrow sorrow vitamin E Sarovar la
moneda new era must be tactical a dis
feeding water source or oval ebony to
Malay apprentice mmm secure sheeter
football he shall never name a lemon for
her money volcanic animal fodder in a
killer Arusha leader must know as malice
150 version gorgeous
my mother my burger the intellect to
Colorado vegan dumber than war magatsu
Porsha Nene relaxer romantic and in the
thousands
anybody portable - and hey we were
formal a gray ivory singapura marilah
kita bersama his school gonna release
Fallujah Tiana annapoorni when you crack
open water to generate a tiara my
tickity Malakian era humor monotony
survey de Medici Chapel every dirty
gianopolous bit over some ogre every
porno Pedroza anomaly sahaja yoga you
noble Veronica lady 7 Emily Rasta
entourage ha Sabatini hallo Bugaboo uwah
Bala
political Sevilla Manila admirable
quality Hooper new pony raja gopura in
germany cover family mati
- Sandoval I may linger forever
[Music]
this next student of life is a master
inventor with over 3,000 patents to his
name and his lightbulb moments just
keeps getting brighter meet you shiro
Nakamatsu you may notice his name is
spelled mahkumat he dropped the letter U
because he says an 8 letter name is
easier to remember but he still wants
you to pronounce it you got a duck dr.
Nakamatsu score key inventions brought
him worldwide recognition inventions
like the Chianti on booths with springs
that put an extra bounce in your step
there's dr. Nakamatsu Suri Breck's it
looks like a lazy boy but the doc says
the darn thing enhances brain power then
there's the gold golf putter that paints
when you strike the ball Oh would you
look at that you know you've made it
when the streets are named after you but
make no mistake dr. Nakamatsu his
inventions aren't all noisy golf clubs
and bouncy shoes he claims to have
invented the floppy disk that's right
that floppy disk retractable landing
gear a widely used kerosene pump and
even the digital watch to maintain his
hyper creativity dr. Nakamatsu keeps his
mind and body in shape
that lightweight inventor Thomas Edison
said genius is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration is that your secret dr.
Nakamatsu yeah
it is patient announcer on your name you
know sannomiya
static guru matter camel toe toe toe
having example changes as an Oliver
today bin Laden Patoka Jeon abandoned
temple
ich sie hier nur donor has no creative
kana dynamic groom that's me in the math
menu ax it's more Beethoven die gonna
die son lacked stamina barrage of the
Jeremiah Thomason this is no not animal
new row to hoe
[Music]
monopoly money most of the science Oona
nonny Marin economist vision on academic
achievement as much the sodium opposite
AHA so - - Oh Raymond told you go to
attend a cinema no date end rail go by
omedetou tow women tonight Oh sighs Oh
Tina Joe Maddon NOP Sinica hots mazurka
doctor cotton choose you cannot remember
[Music]
that Shiva is your name is Jesse Grahm
cried mr. attacks were pending vanished
dr. Nakamatsu saw the cancer as an
opportunity it was his greatest
challenge to invent his way out of an
impossible corner he developed his own
personal cancer treatment
this includes a meticulously documented
diet and a new invention to fight the
cancer
he calls the Gangan robe
the doctors gave him one year to live
that was five years ago
[Music]
'it actua qju each side is not tasty
Lauren to optimism what actua welcome -
una empanada promised Messiah Yeshua
Sima de Mayo
Nana actua to eat or not
Sergio multimap that I don't want
selenium
finally a 75 year old dancing queen who
rocked the fitness world by putting the
Jazz in exercise I grew up a dancer I
walked into that dance studio and I
think even at 3 I knew it would be my
life's passion when I started teaching I
didn't know there was a void in the
fitness industry I was doing my passion
I love to dance I love to share it with
other people
never knowing that it would evolve in
where it is today but I'm sure as heck
glad at [ __ ] it's a thick
exercise Jazzercise has many definitions
it's a dance fitness class that couples
cardiovascular training but also
strength training and muscle work as
well in 1969 I was teaching a very
strict jazz dance class there are a lot
of women in my classes and they would
come and go they didn't stay and that
bugged me that's what gave me the idea
to do what I did to make it fun and
simple and that caught on and then it
just grew Jazzercise has become a huge
community all around the world we have
today about 8,500 franchisees globally
it just got bigger and bigger and bigger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I first started teaching there
wasn't really an option for women it was
so male-dominated you got to put your
feet about there and wrap it up okay now
turn to somebody and say good morning
okay
so I don't think women really thought
about coming to class as it being a
fitness class it was something that was
fun they made friends they sweat and
then they saw their bodies change but it
goes beyond that there's a real
community to our classes step back
Jazzercise just brings everything to
light it makes me physically well it
makes me mentally well and besides I get
to meet my friends and see all my
friends I feel like this community or
the family I like to use family instead
I think it's a family here like we come
and we support each other
I can't do without you you know that
don't you
I just always wanted people to come in
the door and feel good about themselves
and feel like they were home yes you
just start with abduction okay so no
introduction just starts right off the
bat
yes okay when I come up with new
routines there's really a lot of
different things that are mixed together
to make that happen I will select songs
my daughter Shanna who's president of
the company will select songs and we'll
work together touch back we videotape
all that material and then it gets
streamed to our franchisees everywhere
all over the world how about let's do
life as a dance floor okay sounds good
okay now give me three lunges one two it
takes us about ten weeks we do 30 to 35
different routines so it's something new
every ten weeks and push push three
lunges one two
I love teaching I love doing
choreography those two things are my
favorite part of what I do it keeps me
going forward I feel really lucky
because Jazzercise has really enabled me
to experience so many different kinds of
situations
I've been able to run the Olympic torch
we've been able to do the opening
ceremonies for the 1984 Olympics to
dance in those we've done numerous NFL
half times MB a half times we have been
able to do different kinds of
presentations throughout the world
I had no blueprint I had no master plan
I am more than blessed to be a part of
this community we're celebrating our
fiftieth anniversary this year and
people always say to me are you still
teaching when I aren't you who don't you
want to retire you know I'm going to do
this as long as I can walk
[Music]